so remember last time we were looking at
reverse chain rule
for polynomials right and this is this
is not chain rule here this is just
regular old you know normal sign x
normal cos x okay
so you keep your table going i'm going
to drop myself up a new one
okay so how can we do chamber now you
only do
simple ones remember when we were
addressing
the uh primitive of something like this
okay that was fine when i multiplied by
a number like two
okay i just had to divide by two later
on to compensate right
but we got into trouble if we did
something like that
it all just went it just blew to pieces
okay so the same way
when you're thinking about reverse
channel forum for trig functions okay
what you'll find is
you'll just have you know constant
coefficients basically okay
so let's think of one how about sine
2x okay now it's derivative
use chain rule okay do the inside
do the outside what's the inside
it's just two right then you do the
outside sine turns into
cos no problems
okay now because i multiply it right
multiply by the derivative of the inside
when i differentiate it
when i anti-differentiate i ought to
expect
not multiplication but division right
so dividing by two so a half
right and sine came from
negative cos right so let's slap that
minus sign up in front
now does it work does it work should we
just try it out
quickly if i were to differentiate this
thing
okay you do the um you do the inside
right so i'm going to multiply by two
i've got this minus a half floating up
there and then you do the outside
because turns into minus sign and the
constant vanishes right
so cancel cancel cancel cancel looks
good
okay so it works we're going to divide
through
by whatever that is instead of
multiplying and uh
just watch out for your science because
like like before things can flip around
okay so to get rid of this test
what about plus 2x
actually let's let's skip the two let's
make it some constant
for um let's make it a real number okay
if i were to differentiate what would i
get cos turns into
minus minus minus so minus
a sine ax
okay so being that i multiplied going
this way i'm going to divide
going this way what did cos come from
just just regular sign yeah so 1 over a
sine x m i plus three
okay um tan is going to work the same
sec squared is going to work the same so
you know for instance if i had second
squared
ax okay just follow the pattern where
would you expect that it came from
one divide and sec squared comes from
10 right so tan
ax that's your positive okay
okay now by the way um at least the way
i've written it here maybe i can change
this to you can change this to an a
on yours as well um these results are so
important right
that um they actually give these to you
for free
on a little sheet of paper called the um
table of standard integrals because
later when this is
connected they give this to you in the
exam
um in our exams and in the actual hsc
the department of administration says
here free cheat sheet
the board of studies says studies
so yeah now now because they give it to
you do you not have to learn this
answer no no way because
no one actually looks at the table
standard integrals because if you don't
know the results well enough that you've
got to go and look at the sheet
then you're probably going to make some
errors anyway i just kind of treat that
sheet as a sort of like
safety cushion generally not good paper
um material because they are laminated
they could be they might be sort of
decent frisbee material but anyway just
don't take someone's eyes
a lot more complicated okay
so um the short answer is it depends
so for instance let's do something just
a little simpler okay something like
that now we unfortunately
we can't just divide through by by the
the 2x okay and that was what i was
trying to illustrate what we did
when we did this one i think we did that
i think we saw what happened we tried to
use reverse chain rule on it and divided
through by 2x
and we found it just blew things apart
okay it didn't work
so you can't just divide through by
actual functions of x divided through by
constants
no problem and the reason why is because
you can take constants in and out of a
derivative or an anti-derivative just as
you please
okay if they were to give you a question
like this and eventually you'll meet
things like this
what they'll give you is a substitution
they'll be like a part a and they'll say
they'll say differentiate you know some
weird functions
sometimes sometimes they'll say
differentiate this
and you end up at this they might even
say show that the derivative of x is
equal to that
okay and then they'll say you know in
part b
hence you know find the primitive or
integrate you know whatever you're up to
um this on the basis of the fact that
you know it's primitive is going to look
something like this
okay but we'll deal with those kinds of
questions later because
um they're not expecting you to it's not
in a form that you're expected to have
memorized right
every single one is different you'll get
a new one every single year it's hard to
predict but we'll do plenty of practice
questions you'll see what happens
okay all right does any questions about
any of those results
yep okay
yeah i'll give you the shape are there a
few other people who want to categorize
it
okay yeah jesse what's the derivative
i think not that it's a particularly
useful result
but you could yeah that's exactly what
it is that's all it is
okay